c'est une grande première dans
l'histoire de la vème république un
ex-président jugés pour corruption
un scandale qui restera dans les annales
selon les mots du principal intéressé
pour mieux comprendre remontons quelques
années en arrière en 2011 plus
exactement avec cette déclaration du
fils de mouammar kadhafi tout d'abord il
faut dire que sarkozy rende l'argent
qu'il a accepté de la libye pour
financer sa campagne électorale
c'est nous qui avons financé sa campagne
et nous en avons la preuve
nous sommes prêts à tout révéler la
première chose que l'on demandé à ce
clown c'est de rendre l'argent au peuple
libyen
nous lui avons accordé une aide afin
qu'il oeuvre pour le peuple libyen mais
il nous a déçus
rendez nous notre argent nous avons tous
les détails les comptes bancaires les
documents et les opérations de transfert
nous révélerons tout prochainement après
ses déclaration corroborée notamment par
le premier ministre libyen de l'époque
une enquête est ouverte par la justice
française à la fin de l'année 2013 les
juges décident de placer celui qui n'est
plus président sur écoute
deux téléphones portables font alors
visé par le juge d'instruction du pôle
financier du tribunal de grande instance
de paris
très vite le magistrat en question
comprend que nicolas sarkozy utilise une
autre ligne pour communiquer une ligne
secrète au nom d'un certain paul bismuth
qui ils utilisent en général pour
s'adresser à son avocat maître thierry
herzog mis sur écoute à son tour en
janvier 2014 cette ligne permet aux
enquêteurs de découvrir que nicolas
sarkozy est préoccupé par une décision
que doit rendre la cour de cassation
dans le cadre de l' affaire bettencourt
et obtient même d information sur cette
procédure l'ex-président un informateur
gilbert azibert premier avocat général à
la cour de cassation les conversations
téléphoniques retranscrite par les
magistrats semblent révéler ce que
l'avocat attend comme rétribution pour
ces fuites
il m'a dit j'ai déjeuné avec l'avocat
général g voilà il a bossé
il va y avoir un poste qui se libère au
conseil d'état monégasque et il était
bien placé mais simplement il me dit je
sais pas demandez peut-être qu'il faudra
que j'aie un coup de pouce mais je lui
dis tu rigoles avait ce que tu fais
n'oublie pas de dire un mot pour gilbert
qu'on lui donne un coup de main
tu peux lui dire que je suis là bas et
que je vais faire la démarche auprès du
ministre d'état demain ou après demain
ces documents suffisent pour qu'en
octobre 2010 est le parquet national
financier estime qu'il existe je cite
des charges suffisantes à l'encontre de
nicolas sarkozy et de thierry herzog
les deux hommes sont mises en examen
pour corruption et trafic d'influencé
ce qui consiste pour une personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique a
sollicité ou accepté un avantage en
échange d'un acte lui permet sa fonction
ou en échange de son influence réelle ou
supposée sur une décision
sauf que beaucoup d'éléments met en
doute la culpabilité de nicolas sarkozy
car gilbert azibert n'a finalement
jamais eu ce poste au conseil d'état de
monaco et cette conversation captée
quelques jours après ces enregistrements
nous explique pourquoi je n'ai pas voulu
intervenir
je ne connais pas plus que ça et je ne
sais pas exactement ce qu'il a fait ça
ne me pose pas de problème en soi mais
si tu veux je ne vais pas sorti d'en
parler j'ai pas envie une conversation
enregistrée cette fois sur la ligne
officielle de l'ex-chef d'état ce qui
interpelle les enquêteurs cette fois ils
soupçonnent nicolas sarkozy et thierry
herzog d'avoir été mise au courant de la
mission écoute de la ligne paul bismuth
une possible le taux est évoquée
s'ensuit une affaire dans la sphère où
le nom d'eric dupond-moretti actuel
ministre de la justice apparaît mais
elle est classée sans suite
aujourd'hui la ligne de défense de
nicolas sarkozy paraît donc solide
la justice n'ayant aucune preuve
matérielle d'une intervention de sa part
en faveur de gilbert azibert au point
que les défenseurs des accusés
s'interroge sur le zèle des jules dans
ce dossier au bout de six ans
d'instruction judiciaire on en arrive à
six phrases que l'on peut considérer
comme équivoque
mais voilà vous mettez sarkozy monaco
cour de cassation dans le titre et ça
fait de la dynamite une dynamique dont
la justice entend bien tenté d'allumer
la mèche car à ses yeux il n'est pas
nécessaire de rendre le service demandé
à la personne que l'on se doit
le seul fait de lui faire mieux
tu es suffi pour que soit établi le
fameux trafic d'influencé
les trois prévenus contestent ce qu'il
nomme un pacte de corruption
comme ses co prévenus l'ex chef d'état
risquent jusqu'à dix ans
d'emprisonnement une amende d'un million
d'euros et l'interdiction d'exercer
toute fonction publique de manière
définitive ou pendant une certaine
période qui varie selon les affaires
pour l'heure nicolas sarkozy semble
confiant et se dit victime d'un
acharnement judiciaire
oui car un autre procès l'attend au
printemps celui de la sphère à bygmalion
concernant le dépassement de ces frais
lors de la campagne présidentielle de
cerné par les affaires nicolas sarkozy
n'a pas fini de fréquenter les tribunes